elle c'est stéphanie fera part elle est
devenue la première femme à arbitrer un
match de ligue à masculine
une première historique pour l'arbitrage
féminin mais le chemin a été long car
dans les années 60 il était plus facile
de parler mariage à une arbitre que de
football
j'espérais vous marier un jour oui et
vous pensez que si vous étiez marié vous
arbitres y est quand même oui pourquoi
pas oui photo pourquoi pas eh bien oui
pourquoi pas alors que le football
féminin commence à se développer dans
les années 70 il est encore difficile
pour une arabie d'être prise au sérieux
sur un terrain
d'autant que certains joueurs pouvaient
se montrer plutôt insultante s'est
jamais vraiment de gros problèmes enfin
une fois qu'un joueur était vraiment
très excité quand je lis ce que je fais
il avait commencé avec et sans char
remarques sexistes ou encore comment
faire déplacer le chemin vers l'égalité
est encore long pourtant à la même
époque
d'autres joueurs plus respectueux
approuvé cette présence féminine vous
préférez un arbitre homme ou un arbitre
femmes
moi ça me fait rien fait rien on vous
êtes habitués avec cette demoiselle
oui monsieur presque tous les match
amical qu'on fait l arbitre on n'est pas
déçu il faut cependant attendre les
années 90 pour que l'arbitrage féminin
soit enfin reconnu
alors ça c'est super en 1994
laurent guyot est une pionnière elle est
la première femme à arbitrer un match
masculin au niveau professionnel genou
un avenir je dirais un arbitre je me dis
que si une femme a les capacités pour
arbitrer ce niveau là il n'y a pas de
raison que parce que justement c'est une
femme elle et pour sa chance deux ans
plus tard c'est au tour de nesle
de démocratiser un peu plus l'arbitrage
féminin en 1996 un brin impressionné par
l'événement elle devient la première
arbitres féminines à officie en tant qu
arbitre de touche lors d'un match de
première division masculine
je voyais pas le parc de cette façon
secrète de la télévision c'est vrai que
c'est impressionnant
je pensais que les tribunes étaient plus
loin et ont fait elles sont proches du
terrain et je suis très très contente
d'être ici
dernièrement c'est donc stéphanie fera
par qui s'est fait un nom en arbitrant
amiens strasbourg
mais le chemin est encore long en france
en terme d'égalité en 2019
en france seuls lille femme officier en
tant qu'arbitre sur les 25000 que
comptait la fff
loin bien loin du handball et ses 8000
60 arbitres féminines sur 28 milles 130
[Musique]